so when I came to America obviously I
knew nothing about football there was no
lineage then I moved to Edison New
Jersey in the summer of 1982 and I went
outside because that's what kids in the
80s did and found some kids playing with
a Nerf football and my friend Eric
Godfrey looked me in the face and said
who do you like I'm not sure if I even
knew what he said because I'm not sure I
understood English fully yet and he said
you're a New York Jets fan and I said
okay and these kids really accepted me
the next day they played with me the
next day and they became my friends so I
jumped on with them and I've basically
watched every snap of a New York Jets
game since everybody had a Jets Jersey
and I wanted one we couldn't afford
stuff like that it's not what immigrants
do you know go out and buy a 30 Jets
Jersey so my mom knitted me one and so I
have it it's my prized possession it's
literally my prized possession and I've
created a fairy tale in my mind
somewhere around second or third grade
that I was going to go from not being
able to afford a Jersey to owning the
whole damn thing the quest to buy the
Jets is my happiness